يوميات الفيديو لمتطوع أوكراني شاب
مبرد أو سمكة قرش
[تصفيق]
سجل في الصباح الأول
للغزو
استعدادًا للدفاع عن أمته في
البداية يقول إنه لم يشعر
بعبء الحرب
ولكن بعد ذلك تم إرسال أكولا  إلى الجبهة الشرقية
[تصفيق]
كان هذا أصعب وقت في
حياتي، يقول
أنه من المستحيل وصفه
بالكلمات
حيث تفشل الكلمات، هذه الصور تحكي
قصته،
قصة آلاف
الجنود الشباب الأوكرانيين،
يقول هولا إنه أصيب بارتجاجات شديدة
من المدفعية  وضربات الصواريخ
وهو الآن في
مركز لإعادة تأهيل الصحة العقلية بالقرب من كييف، هل تعتقد أن
الصراع سيكون
مثل ما شهدته عندما
تطوعت في ذلك اليوم
لأكون صادقًا، لم أتوقع مثل هذه الحرب، كما
يقول عندما ذهبت إلى الحرب اعتقدت
سيكون كل شيء مختلفًا وعندما
تصل إلى هناك، ليس الأمر كما تعتقد،
مرحبًا، الجو بارد
مخيف وجائع ووحيد
[موسيقى]
يقول أكولا إن الجو هادئ هنا
في مركز فوريست جليد، يتلقى الجنود ما
يصل إلى شهر من العلاج، وكان
القرار الأصعب بالنسبة لهم هو الإرسال
يعودون للقتال وربما يموتون،
الشيء الأكثر أهمية الآن هو أنهم
ينجون ويبقون على قيد الحياة، لذا كرئيس للصحة
العقلية بعد الحرب، سنساعدهم في
صحتهم واجتماعهم
في هذا البلد الآن، يجب على كل رجل محترم أن
ينضم إلى الحرب شابًا وصغيرًا.  مهمتهم القديمة
هي إنقاذك من البكاء،
وأوكرانيا تدعو بشكل عاجل إلى
متطوعين مثل هؤلاء،
ولا تنشر أرقام الضحايا، لكن
مسؤولًا أمريكيًا كبيرًا قدر
منذ أشهر أنه ربما يكون هناك مائة ألف
جندي قتلوا وجرحوا،
وهذا الرقم أعلى بلا شك الآن بعد
أسابيع فقط.  في السابق، لم يكن العديد من هؤلاء المجندين
يحملون بندقية، لكن قائدهم، وهو
طبيب نفسي مدرب، يحمل
العلم الأوكراني على ظهره
ليرفعه فوق المدن المحررة.
في الوقت الحالي، أشعر بخوف أقل على
نفسي من خوفي على المقاتلين، يقول
الملازم إن بعضًا من فريقي لم يفعلوا ذلك.  لقد رأيت
القتال ولدي مسؤولية كبيرة
لقيادتهم إلى الأمام،
أريد فقط أن يفهم الناس بوضوح، يقول
أكولا أن الرجال الذين كانوا
هناك منذ البداية لن
يقفوا إلى الأبد،
يقول إنه ليس جاهزًا بدنيًا أو عقليًا
ولكن في  في غضون أيام قليلة يمكن إعادته
للقتال،
هذه هي وظيفتي، كما يقول ويجب أن أفعل
ذلك من غيرنا إن لم يكن نحن ديفيد ماكنزي سي إن إن
كيب